hey youtubers is Charlie and this week
as promised my Game of Thrones bonus
video is going to be all about the
faceless men since we're still pretty
season five I'm going to do a history of
their order and then talk about how the
show might use them just based on
castings and filming locations we've
seen so far there are religious society
that worships the many-faced God and
engages in the trade of assassination
it's part of their worship so whenever
you join their order you're not just
learning to kill people you're learning
to serve the many-faced God so far on
the show the best look we've got an ad
an actual faceless man is jack and Hagar
he's a devout religious assassin which
is why he speaks in backwards riddles at
the other end of the spectrum you can
think about that common assassin like
Karl played by burn gorman this last
season in season four he was an assassin
at King's Landing
I guess you could say he worshipped
himself but you get the idea
fiza's men are some of the most highly
trained highly sought after highly
feared assassins in the world and I just
want to remind everyone that the weekly
book giveaway is still going so all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if you're just finding me for the
first time you have no idea what's going
on I do weekly Game of Thrones videos
tomorrow I'm gonna do a Q&A video for
this video where I'll announce the
winner of the giveaway so history of the
faceless men the religion came first the
worship of the mini face God it
originated in the Valyrian slave mines
this is old valaria pre doom the tale
goes that a man heard all the slaves
whispering prayers to different gods for
deliverance via Death and decided that
they were all speaking to the same God
thus many gods with many faces became
one God with many faces eventually it
led to that man giving the gift of mercy
or the gift of death to the most
desperate slaves eventually he also gave
it to the Masters killing the Masters
it's rumored that the order grew to the
point that they were able to influence
the doom in Valyria like they were
somehow involved in it coming to pass
whether they were granted a boon by the
many-faced God or they killed anyone
capable of stopping it that's only a
rumor after the doom they eventually set
themselves up as a proper order in
Braavos their guilds home the temple is
called the house of black and white in
terms of where it's located in Braavos
specifically I already did a big Braavos
video earlier this year where I did a
detailed map layout of the city so I'll
just add links for that at the end of
this video and in the description so you
can watch it if you want now people that
join the order become faceless men
that's in
léa group inside the religion but women
can also become faceless men and
children too in very very rare cases the
different names of the many-faced God
are just based on region in cohort it's
called the Black Goat and UT it's called
the Lion of the night and in the faith
of the seventh it's called the stranger
whenever I first started getting into
Game of Thrones as a series I actually
started to wonder if the many-faced God
was just another name for different gods
in the series like if the faith of the
seven were just different aspects of the
many-faced God I tend to believe it the
way the books presented that the
many-faced God is just one of the seven
but not all of the seven I know there's
a big debate that's been going on since
the books were originally published
think of it in terms of the great other
enroller the red God George Martin based
those two gods on Zoroastrianism which
states that there is a creator who is
not present in the world he's
represented by divine beings and great
acts of nature there's no evil that's a
part of him so evil comes from other
sources it's really interesting in that
religion the word for evil translates to
lies the forces of good try to
neutralize evil so there's this back and
forth push-pull thing going on with the
creator being completely distant from it
in any physical sense so for all intents
and purposes if the great other enroller
can be different gods then all the other
gods can be different gods too so moving
on explaining the faceless ones belief
system whenever they kill someone they
see it as a mercy they're releasing
someone from the burden of life the
death of the target is like a sacrament
to the many-faced God in the temple they
also allow people to come in and commit
assisted suicide by drinking poison
whenever someone wishes to kill themself
they just come in barter for a price and
the faceless ones give them the poison
in a black cup so some other big rules
state that when you enter the order you
forsake your identity and you're only
allowed to kill the targets that you're
hired to kill you couldn't just go out
and murdering anyone you wanted unless
someone named them to you like Arya name
to Jack and in season two so the house
of black and white their temple has a
bunch of different levels they're all
really interesting on the main ground
level area there are statues to over 30
different gods people could come in and
light candles or just stay in worship
but this is also the area where people
come to seek help buying poison and
killing themselves it's not a church
though they don't hold services like you
see in the faith of the seven priests
can assist people when requested though
so then you go down to the first
sublevel that's where the priests and
the acolytes sleep then
hello that is where the servants sleep
then on the third level there's the holy
sanctum this is where they keep all the
faces that they collect they collect and
preserve the faces of the people that
come to them to die and then use those
faces as disguises part of their
training is mastering the ability to use
them like when we see jackin changes
face at the end of season two like I
said everyone is required to give their
name up whenever they join the order but
there are several important people
there's the kindly man the handsome man
the fat fellow the stern face the
squinter the lordling the starved man
plague face the wave and the alchemist
there's no telling how the show is going
to treat these characters or if it's
gonna cast any of them so I'm just going
to wait till we actually start seeing
episodes or casting notices to talk more
about them but they're not a massive
group of people like the faith of the
seven or the order of the red God like
they don't try to go out and convert
people to their religion that's why
largely they're just localized to
Braavos like their home base so a big
part of hiring them to kill people is
the bartering process and it just
depends the cost just depends on how
important the person is that you want
them to kill they will kill anyone
though anyone in the world king or
peasant it's just that the price for
killing a king or queen is astronomical
they do accept more than just money
though in exchange for a contract it
might involve some non-monetary thing a
really high value thus far on the show
we haven't seen a whole lot of faceless
men but in the books where we are in the
story on the show they actually have
come up several times in the first book
Robert Baratheon small Council thinks
about hiring a faceless man to kill
Daenerys this was all before the Dragons
were born they decided not to just
because it was too much money in book to
re of course meets faceless man Jack and
Hagar in book three whenever Arya is
with the Brotherhood without banners an
old woman called the ghost of high heart
tells a story where she said in a dream
she sees a man without a face waiting on
a bridge that swayed and swung so there
are some things that the show has not
done but remember at the end of season 2
whenever Jack and left Arya he gave her
the Braavosi coin and taught her that
she could give it to any Braavos EU ship
captain and say the words fallar
Margulis and they would take her to
Braavos it's like a Willy Wonka golden
ticket to WTF land and you could just
see the excitement on Arya's face that
she's on the boat on the way to Braavos
but there's also this real
sinister connotation behind it just
because the meanings of those words in
high valyrian it means all men must die
the formal response Valar dohaeris is
all men must serve I like to think of
the exchanges meaning all men must serve
death but that's just my interpretation
so in my previous video I posted a
picture from a new filming location that
looked kind of like Braavos we weren't
really sure there have been a bunch more
pictures since then none of the
characters that they announced the
comic-con were Braavosi characters but
Maisie Williams did call herself no one
on the panel which is something right
out of book four so it sounds like the
show is going to do a version of Braavos
maybe a truncated version it won't be
exactly what's in the books they'll
probably just shrink down the number of
characters and the house of black and
white till it's just a smaller part of
the story it's possible that they'll
make casting announcements for Braavosi
characters as they start to film those
scenes I think I mentioned it earlier
already but the child of the forest from
the finale last year she wasn't cast
till November so they'll continue to
make casting announcements for the next
couple of months I'll be sure to mention
any of them as they come along so like I
said there will be a Q&A video for this
tomorrow so be sure to send me all of
the questions since I finally had my
last day of my job Friday I can spend
more time talking to you guys so please
do ask questions so I can answer all of
them so like I said you can click here
for the link to that Braavos video where
I go into that detailed map breakdown of
all the different buildings in the city
and you can click here to get the Q&A
video all the annotation as soon as I
post it tomorrow thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives